hey guys welcome to IJ likes the show
where I cover a bunch of food things
would happen in the past week as always
if you have cool things that you would
like you to include in this video either
tweet it to me posted on Facebook or
leave me a comment below I always like
to start these videos off with cool
videos that I have found from the past
week and a lot of you guys know that I'm
obsessed with pigs so obviously when I
saw this freaking Pig getting a little
tummy rub the cuteness overload was just
overloaded a lot of you divergent fans
have probably already seen the movie and
you've probably already heard this song
but I haven't seen the movie and I
haven't heard the song until today
Lonnie
I cannot wait to see the movie I really
love the books although the third one
not so much
let me know what you guys thought of the
movie no spoilers I mean if you spoil it
whatever I mean I read the book so I
already know what is supposed to happen
I trying to find a video for you guys of
a puppy chasing a child because
something about that is very funny but I
found this instead so I think is also
just as cute to think it makes the cute
cut moving on to gaming and technology I
actually forgot all of my topics because
it's been such a long time they didn't I
J likes but this past week two weeks
three weeks a lot of stuff has been
happening in gaming for me I was super
excited about titanfall and I actually
have not even had a chance to play it so
let me tell you what I'm doing tonight
actually it's probably gonna be playing
Call of Duty because this weekend the
call duty championship happened so
congratulations to complexity who ended
up winning four hundred thousand dollars
for just being really freaking good at
Call of Duty is a million dollar
tournament so thirty two of the best
teams around the world were here in Los
Angeles playing call of duty watching
people play they're so good that I'm
sitting there for like 16 hours watching
people playing this game and the only
thing that I wanted to do who's go home
and play so that's what I'm gonna do
today for IJ book club this week I am so
excited because this is such an amazing
book it's written by Adam Braun it's
called the promise of a pencil and he
started the pencils of promise
foundation and I'm so excited because I
really think you guys should check out
this book and the best part about it is
if you guys aren't fans of reading you
can have it be read to you with audible
a lot of you guys are already on audible
but if you're not you can get a free
book and a 30-day free trial by using
audible.com slash I just need use the
link get yourself a book and uh if you
guys already have read this book let me
know what you guys think of it and if
you do download it and then read it you
can come back to this video and then let
me know what you think of it and last up
is fashion and beauty like I love having
this because sometimes I have cool
things to show you but on a normal daily
basis I've got I have got nothing that
cool I just did a restock of some of my
Arcana or Kona products it's called the
peptide hydrating complex and I've been
using this for probably four years I use
a lot of other stuff in my skin too but
this is the one thing that has been
student I also use a bunch of our
cleansers and I just bought some of
their shampoo for the first time and um
I like it I like it anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this quick little episode
of IJ likes if you guys have any other
things that you may like me to conclude
in a future episode you know what to do
I'll see you later